ce samedi 7 octobre yasmine neuf ans à
travailler son swing sous l'oeil de son
père au golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines
elle fait partie des six ans novice qui
ont participé à cette sixième édition
dans la golf expérience un événement
gratuit encadrés par des experts et
elengy puis c'était plutôt rigolo les
façons dont tu l'a présenté à des bals
où j'ai réussi des bals où j'ai pas
réussi et bien oui c'est très très très
bien c'est très bien et je pense qu'il
faut il pouvoir faire ce genre de
l'expérience encore plus souvent la
renouveler depuis les inciter à leur
donner envie leur donner envie de taper
dans la balle pour aider les novices ou
les joueurs confirmés à progresser des
capteurs ont été installés sur les
différents ateliers
objectif les aider à améliorer le jeu
long et le jeu court avec ça on va
pouvoir aider le joueur à travailler les
bons points aller travailler dans le bon
sens pas aller dans un chemin qui va pas
être le bon pour le voir 3 corriger plus
facilement les défauts du joueur avec
des données mathématiques tous les coûts
devraient être bons et précis est
important de bien se connaître soi même
d'avoir
tous les paramètres qui influent sur la
performance en parallèle des activités
sportives les golfeurs en herbe ont pu
découvrir en avant première un village
ambulant dédié à la ryder cup 2018 qui
se déroulera au golf national
le but c'est de parler aux saint
quentinois et leur expliquer ce qu'est
la ryder cup fortement donc on a toutes
une tente de promotion où on parle
souvent de la ryder cup on à la
documentation à remettre aux visiteurs
on a une tante qui détient la réalité
virtuelle
enfin c'est une visite virtuelle du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
par les saint quentinois sont jamais
venus sur ce site exceptionnel
on leur propose du coup d'une manière
très immersive il est très émotionnel de
découvrir ce site à partir de novembre
ce village ambulant va s'exporter à
l'extérieur des frontières du golf
national 20 événements sont déjà
programmés sur 11 communes de saint
quentin en yvelines jusqu'à
l'organisation de la ryder cup en
septembre 2018